The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: OK, so I
feel I should have brought
pizza instead of math problems.
I mean, but this is
our final, final hour.
Open for any questions,
any discussion
about Fourier topics.
Looking toward tomorrow
evening's exam.
And, well, hoping you'll
find the whole course
useful at many
times in the future.
So, somebody emailed me
that the posted solution,
so I just posted
a quick solution
to the un-collected
homework ten,
and so I haven't even
looked to see what
did it say for this question.
But what is the answer?
If I convolve the delta function
with the delta function,
what do I get?
Delta, right.
If I convolve
anything with delta
I get delta because I'm
over in the other space.
I'm multiplying by one.
Yeah, so if I use the
convolution rule to go over
to the other space, where this
becomes just one times one
I'm getting one, and transform
back and I've got delta.
Well that question won't
be on tomorrow's exam.
But I thought we could
deal with that fast.
Now I'm open to questions
about any topic.
Homework or not.
Yeah, thanks.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: I could try.
Did I make up the exam?
Probably.
Yeah, I'll recognize it.
OK, alright, I'll read it out.
OK, so this an exam from
2005, not that far back.
OK, so it has some questions.
Shall I tell you what
the whole question is,
but it looks like
this Part D is sort
of separate from the others.
But why not, this gives us
some questions to think about.
So if I just read
out the questions.
One was, find the coefficients
of-- The function is e^(-x).
That would naturally
occur to me as a function
that you could-- So,
from zero to 2pi.
And then periodic.
Always good to graph it.
So will e to the
minus x look like?
It'll come down to,
much steeper than that,
but that would do it.
So that's e^(-x).
Here it's one, and
here it's e^(-2pi).
And then repeat, repeat, repeat.
So find its Fourier
coefficients.
I'll just say what the
question is and you can ask me.
And then what's the decay rate.
Oh, maybe you can tell
me the decay rate.
Even before you tell
me the coefficient.
What would the decay rate
be if I expressed this
as a combination of
Fourier terms, harmonics.
How quickly will those
coefficients drop off?
So 1/k, only.
That's right, 1/k, because this
function has a jump at zero.
Well, at zero and again at 2pi,
at every one of those points.
It has a jump, I guess,
of about this distance,
between one and that number.
Which would be the jump that we
would see of course every time.
Yeah, so the coefficients
would decay like 1/k.
Then it asked to compute the sum
of those coefficients squared.
OK, so how can we find the sum
of those coefficients squared
even before I know
what they are?
Well, you know
the answer, right?
How am I going to
do this problem?
Yeah, so I'm looking for the sum
of the squares of coefficients
and then there's
this magic trick.
What is it that helps me to
find that sum of squares?
How do I go about that?
I connect it to the integral
of the function squared.
Integral zero to 2pi of
the function squared.
And you remember
the reason, and I've
left a little space
for the fudge factor.
2pi, or 1/(2pi), we can figure
out what it is by taking
a simple case.
Yeah, why don't we take a simple
case to figure out should there
be a 2pi or a 1/(2pi) or what?
What's a simple case here?
Suppose I take f(x)=1.
Suppose I take the function
f(x)=1, then the right side--
So if f(x) is one, the right
side would be 2pi, I guess,
the integral of one.
And the left side would be what?
What would be the
Fourier coefficients
of the constant function?
Well just c_0, the only one
we would have would be c_0,
the constant term, the c_0*e^0.
And it would be one.
So I'd have a one
there, when k is zero,
and otherwise I
wouldn't have anything.
So this would be one
squared, this would be a one.
So I do need to divide by 2pi.
Do you agree with that?
To make it correct I'd better
have a 1/(2pi) to get that
to be right.
OK, and then this gives
me the answer then,
I just do this integral,
e^(-2x), then f is e^(-x).
So f squared would be e^(-2x),
which I can certainly integrate
and get some expression.
Yeah, OK.
So that's a
straightforward part.
And now to the Part D, which you
asked about which is, oh wow.
OK, so now I'm asking
about an equation u, du/dx,
plus u(x) equals
a train of deltas.
So delta(x) made periodic.
Can I write it that way?
So this is the periodic case.
So I'm looking for
a periodic answer.
So I'm in the
Fourier series world
when I take-- I'll be
looking for coefficients, not
the integral transform.
OK.
So alright, so I'm
making it clear.
So how do I proceed now,
with such a problem?
So I've mentioned this morning
that a problem like this
could appear.
So I'm happy to discuss it.
What do I do?
Transform.
Absolutely.
Take Fourier transform.
OK, so what happens when I
take Fourier transforms of u?
Well, I guess, so
we're doing periodic,
so we're going to go
to coefficients, right?
I'll call them, shall I call,
shall-- I think of u(x),
shall I just call
its coefficient c?
It's the only function I have
around so I might as well use
c for it.
So here's the function,
and Fourier takes this
to the set of coefficients, OK.
And the point is that
we can separate--
I mean this is the whole
reason why Fourier's so great.
That we can do each
frequency separately.
So let's see then.
So this has coefficient c_k,
and what are the coefficients,
what's the k-th coefficient, so
this is all the e^(ikx) term.
What's the k-th coefficient of
the derivative? ikc_k, right?
And what's the k-th coefficient
of the delta function?
One, right?
Is that right or is there
1/(2pi) or something?
Is it 1/(2pi)?
OK, 1/(2pi).
Yeah, I guess that's right.
Because the coefficient,
I would have
to take the integral
times, yeah, the integral
with the delta function
will give me the one,
and then there's a 1/2pi.
Right, OK.
So now I've got the answer.
Now I have this
equation at each k.
Following each
eigenvector, following
each separate frequency.
And it's easy to do.
It's just 1/(2pi) And
there's 1+ik, I think.
OK, and now those are the c_k's.
So I think maybe this is it.
Sum from minus infinity,
I know what the c_k is.
2pi(1+ik), times e^(ikx).
That's my u(x), I think.
Had to be, right?
So I just did the sort
of automatic steps.
When I made up
this exam, I don't
know whether I was thinking
I could find out-- Can
I actually do that sum to
produce some function u(x)
that I am familiar with.
I'm not sure.
Anybody reading the
question, so the question
says solve this
differential equation.
Doesn't say what
it means by solve.
Anyway, I've done it.
I guess.
Shall we agree that I
passed on this question?
If we knew some tricky
way to do this addition,
but I don't immediately see it.
So that's good.
OK, you're welcome.
Thanks.
OK, so that was a very
good question to ask.
Because it got,
it got the method
of how do you deal with
a differential equation.
By the way, this could be
a difference equation, too.
That could be u at
x+h minus u at x-h.
Shall I just emphasize that that
wouldn't have been any harder?
u(x+h)-u(x-h) over 2h,
let me take, for example,
plus u equals delta.
This is like I've taken a
centered difference there,
instead of a derivative.
How would you write
a solution to that?
Same method.
So what would the method be?
I'd take transforms.
So here this would
have coefficient c_k,
this would have
coefficients 1/(2pi).
And what would be the
coefficients of these guys?
Well, there's a 1/(2h).
So what are the Fourier
coefficients of u(x+h)?
Just to see that
all these things--
I've got constant
coefficients here.
Why shouldn't Fourier work?
So if it's u(x+h), so there's
an e to the something factor,
right?
When I've shifted a function
then in the transform
I see an e to the i thing.
So let's just see.
If u(x), so if u(x) is
the sum of c_k*e^(ikx),
then u(x+h) would be the sum
of c_k*e^(ik(x+h)), right?
No, nothing surprising there.
So now I'm seeing the factor.
There's c_k, it's multiplied
by the factor e^(ikh).
So this is the same c_k, but
an e^(ikh), from that one.
And this would be the minus, and
this would shift the other way.
So it would be the same
c_k, and probably e^(-ikh).
If I did that right.
Yeah.
Anyway, once again, we
have still linear problem.
This is c_k times
something equals 1/(2pi).
By the way, this thing is
what I would call the transfer
function.
You see that language?
We haven't used
that language much.
Or at all, it's sort of more
of a systems theory, control
theory word.
But hey, we're always doing
the same correct thing.
That's the thing that transfers
the input to the output.
So maybe the transfer
function is one over.
Maybe I include the division
in the transfer function.
So finally I get c_k
is this 1/(2pi) guy,
divided by whatever that was,
1/(2h) times that number,
minus 1/(2h) of that plus one.
Whatever is
multiplying c_k there.
It's a transfer function.
Yeah.
So there's another word which
we could have, and should have,
used before today.
But here it is.
OK, so that's some thoughts
about that question.
Any other direction to go?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Yes. go ahead.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG:
Lab problem 12, OK.
4.5, Fourier
integrals, number 12.
Oh yeah, maybe that was also.
A question was
raised about was it
right on the posted solution.
So maybe not.
Let's see what we want to do.
Yeah I just thought
that was pretty-- I
could remember the day I
thought of this equation.
Integral of u minus derivative
of u equal delta(x).
I thought that's kind of
a cool looking equation.
But I don't know that I've
ever solved it, before.
So integral of u, actually
yeah, I look cheerful,
but-- So I'm finishing
the fourth edition
of the linear algebra book.
Introduction to Linear Algebra.
So I love writing.
I've done all the
writing and now comes
the only horrible part, solving
all those stupid exercises.
So that, you may think of me in
sunny Singapore or somewhere,
but what I'll be doing
is not on the beach.
It's in an office somewhere,
doing Problem 1.1.1,
and two, three, it's not life.
I mean, it's.
But, OK.
Anyway, that looks like
a pretty good equation.
And certainly I'm
going to transform it.
So I can see a little
question coming up.
So am in the Fourier
integral world, yeah.
So I should you use this
notation. u hat of k, right?
Over ik, is that the right
thing when I've integrated?
Yeah.
That's made it smoother.
That's dragging
the function down.
And I guess the one point
that's a little tricky there
is always, are you
dividing by zero.
Because zero is one
of the frequencies.
And so I sort of need u hat
of zero to be zero for this.
So it's looking slightly
dangerous at k=0,
but otherwise it's certainly
improving things by speeding up
the decay rate.
And then this would be minus
ik u hat of k, as we just said.
And this would be
the one, maybe it's
a one in the Fourier
integral world,
where the 2pi went
in a different point.
So I think that's, yeah.
So I would now just,
the usual thing
was the transfer function.
1/(ik)-ik, so that's
my transfer function.
That's multiplying u hat.
Maybe I can simplify
that by putting it
all over ik, one minus ik.
Is it plus k?
Does that look good, or does
that look bad? k squared?
Does that look better?
So I'm wondering, so over
here is k squared over ik,
is that the same
as the minus ik?
Yeah.
Yeah, bring it up and the
minus i squared is one
and I've got k squared.
Yeah, so this looks good.
So that's then, dividing by it
gives me, I'm dividing the one.
So u hat k is one over this.
So it's the transfer function.
One plus k squared.
OK.
I don't know whether
I had in mind
to go any further than this.
Did you get this far, or what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: It said that?
Oh jeez.
I bitterly regret
saying these things.
Yeah, OK.
I don't know u(x).
Did anybody have any luck?
You did.
Did I say it with a derivative?
Oh one, over one plus
k squared, oh yeah.
One over one plus k
squared, we know what to do.
And then ik will
take its derivative.
So what do we do if it's
one over one plus k squared?
That's the one where, that was
the guy which was the e^(-x),
right?
Oh, it's just one side.
No, two sides, isn't it?
Two sides, yeah.
Yeah, we just got a corner.
Yeah, OK.
That's looking good.
And now maybe I need to
divide by two. a is one here
but there is a division by two.
Yeah, that looks good.
OK, and now I take--
This function,
its transform has that.
And now if I want
to multiply by ik
I have to take the derivative.
So I believe with
your help here,
that the derivative
of that is the same.
Can I just take the derivative
while we're looking at it?
I mean e^x is the
most-- You know,
that was created to take
its derivative, right?
So its derivative is itself.
The derivative of
this is a minus.
So I think that maybe that's
the answer. e^x over two,
coming up to 1/2, I guess.
And then-- Oh, well
the picture won't look,
because of that minus sign.
Yeah.
Huh.
Good, because that minus sign,
it's minus e^(-x) over two.
So it starts at minus 1/2.
So there's a jump of one.
Or drop of one.
Is that right, there should
be a drop of one in u hat?
Probably.
Yeah, yeah.
The integral will
be smooth at zero,
where the delta
function's hitting us.
I have a minus sign
and a derivative.
But yeah, doesn't
that look good?
If the derivative has a delta,
the function has a jump.
And with that minus
sign, and with one delta,
the jump should
be a drop of one.
Which is that.
Yeah.
And the integral
minus the derivative
should be otherwise zero.
So again this is not
unrelated to exam questions.
I did all this stuff, and
I really should check,
did I get it right?
Does that solve the
differential equation?
I mean, you could say
of course it does if you
took all these steps right.
But it's wise to check.
Plug it in.
OK, it has the drop of one.
So it deals correctly with the
delta because, the derivative
has a delta.
And things match.
And now what else
do I have to check?
I have to check out all
the other points, right?
I've just checked that yep,
this answer is good at the jump.
The tricky point.
But now what about
all the other points?
So where the delta is
zero, I should just
check that the integral of u,
so what is the integral of u?
Let me just check for the
points left of the origin.
So I'm just going to
look at this part.
Yeah, x negative.
So its integral, what's the
integral of e^x over two?
I guess e^x over two, right?
Minus?
And what's the
derivative of e^x?
Oh, the derivative is also
e^x over two and I get zero,
or x negative.
As I want to.
Because the delta is
zero in that left side.
And similarly on the right side.
It should be OK.
And then the key point was
that the jump was right.
Yeah, so thank you.
That's good.
Yes please.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: What, sorry?
Why did I take the derivative?
What will be the
derivative of this?
Yes, there is.
That's right.
What would be the
derivative of this?
Huh, yeah, good question.
What's the derivative
of this answer.
So it's that, on the left. and
then there's a delta function,
a minus delta, right,
because it's dropped down.
And then the derivative
of that is e^(-x).
Yeah, so if I graph
the derivative, cool.
I graph the derivative, it
looks like the function.
It has a spike going down there.
At the origin, and then the
derivative here is positive.
Right?
This function's coming up.
It's e^(-x) over two.
It's positive, it's there.
Yeah.
Oh wow, that's a nice graph.
So that's the derivative,
this is the graph of du/dx.
Yeah, thanks.
And similarly I could graph the
integral, the integral-- Well,
would you want to
see the integral?
Probably not.
Maybe, yeah.
The integral would probably
look pretty much just like that
but without the delta, yeah.
Cool, isn't that nice?
It's artistic.
That's the derivative,
and the integral
is the same thing
without the delta.
And when you subtract,
you get the delta.
OK, you sure you guys don't
want to come to Singapore
and help with these
problem solutions?
There's plenty for everybody.
OK.
Alright, so another question.
Yeah.
2005.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: OK, alright.
Yeah, which one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: OK, I'll just
read out the whole question.
Yeah.
So this is 2005, Problem 3.
OK it's a half-hat function.
This is Fourier integral,
because it's on the whole line.
And it's half a hat for--
Between zero and one,
the function is coming down.
And then otherwise it's zero.
So its graph, done.
Graph its derivative.
OK, let's graph the
derivative of that function.
Derivative is certainly
zero along there.
Then the derivative
is minus one here.
And then the derivative is zero.
So the derivative looks
to me like it's that, OK.
So yeah, that function--
Is that right?
No.
It's not right.
There's a delta.
That was the tricky
part of the problem.
Right, there's a delta
in the derivative,
right here because of that jump.
There's a delta.
OK.
Good.
Now, is that better?
That's good.
OK.
What's its transform?
The transform of
this derivative.
What's the Fourier transform?
Well, I guess we got two parts.
So this is my function u'(x).
The derivative.
Now, what's u' transform?
So it should be a
function of k, now.
Alright, what do you think?
So it's the sum of two things.
That delta, which Fourier
transforms to one.
And this guy down below
between zero and one,
which was like the
one we did today,
we've got the integral
from zero to one.
Now it happens to be a
minus one e^(-ikx) dx.
And that, of course, we can do.
OK Oh, there's solutions here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Yeah.
So OK, so I think
we're doing alright.
This expression is familiar.
It's 1-e^(-ik) over the ik.
Is that right?
We have a minus.
Is the minus, yeah, I
think the minus looks good.
And yeah, at least, that's
here and it's probably
got the minus signs correct.
So why was it?
I plugged in x=1, and
that's why I got an e^(-ik).
And then I plugged in x=0 and
that's where that one came
from.
OK, so, but your question
was about-- That was it?
Oh, I see.
OK.
Right, and then the next part
asked about the transform
of the original guy.
The transform of
the original guy.
Now, what would be the
transform of the original guy?
The original u.
Right, OK, yeah.
The reason I'm
sort of stuttering
is that if I'm
going to integrate--
I mean, what are you
going to tell me?
What's a quick way to find the
transform of the original u
now?
Divide by ik.
And then I'm all ready to do
that except I'm worried that
k=0.
But it should come
out alright, now.
So I have to hope that this
thing comes out to be zero
at k=0.
Can you see that it does?
What is, yeah?
This is a good point.
What does u hat
at zero represent?
Have you thought about that?
If I look at the Fourier
transform, which I've got here.
So let me write
what I've got here.
I've got here that Fourier
transform of this function.
And if I take the Fourier
transform of any function,
and I look at zero frequency.
What am I seeing?
The average, right.
I'm saying the average.
What's the average
value of that function?
We never thought about that.
But that's fun.
What's the average of this guy?
If I integrate over
the whole line.
Do I get zero?
Yes.
Because I get the integral of
the delta part gives me a one.
But the integral of this box
part gives me a minus one.
So the integral, so this
does equal zero at k=0,
and I can safely do
that division and get,
so now u hat of k is this
expression divided by ik.
So it's one minus this thing.
I'm just copying.
Minus ik, over ik, all
that divided by ik.
And I can, of course,
maneuver that some more
to make it look better.
OK, these are good
questions, because it's
giving me a few functions
to do the standard rules.
Shifting, integrating,
differentiating.
Oh, here's a Christmas present.
What does that mean?
Is the convolution of
this function with itself
the whole hat?
Why is that a Christmas present?
Is the convolution,
the convolution
of that with itself.
So first point, we don't want
to compute a convolution.
You may have
noticed, you have not
computed convolutions
of things like this.
It's not a lot of fun.
Because you have
that integral to do.
And you'd have to
separate out the parts
where it's this and the
part where it's this
and the parts where it's that.
It's not nice.
Much better to multiply
in the transform domain.
Much better.
OK, so if I multiply in
the transform domain,
I don't think I get the
Fourier transform of the hat.
Of the whole hat.
But can you give me
a convincing argument
for why-- This is, here
I'm in the transform domain
and I'm going to
convolve with itself,
so I'm just going to square it.
With the decay rate, what's
the decay rate as it is now?
The decay rate is, yes.
The decay rate is a good key.
So what is the decay
rate right now?
Here's a function with a jump.
So I know that even though
has a slightly messy
looking transform, I
know the decay rate.
It's what, with a jump is 1/k.
OK, so this must
be, and I sort of
do see a k down here,
so that's sensible.
OK, now, if I convolve, then
I multiply in this domain.
So that would give me the
k squared, as you said.
So could that be the
transform of the whole hat?
Does the whole hat
have a-- ooh, could be.
I'm pretty sure the answer's no.
Yeah, no way.
Yeah, I think that
that's the best answer.
I've lost the reason.
Because I'm getting the
k squared decay rate.
If I convolve
something with itself,
that would give me a k
squared, and the decay rate
for the transform of
the hat is a k squared.
But they wouldn't
be the same, yeah.
OK, yeah, I won't.
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Right.
It's just convention.
The difference was that that was
the Fourier integral problem.
Where we put, you
might have noticed
that the 2pi goes on the other--
And this was the Fourier series
problem.
That was its only difference.
So it's just a convention.
And maybe other people would
choose a different convention.
So that is a slight
wiggle in the presentation
that the 2pi in the
Fourier integral section
got moved to the transform
in the other direction.
Yeah, good.
Yes, thanks.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Oh, OK.
I'm really just going by this
rule that if there is a jump
in the function,
and nothing worse,
then the decay rate is
1/k, and if there's a jump
in the derivative, as
there would be here --
so that has a jump in slope --
then the decay rate is one over
k squared and so on.
But those are the main cases.
Yeah, so I'm not using
anything deep there.
And by the way, I realize
here that one MATLAB problem
that I didn't assign this
semester but it's quite fun,
is to actually see
the Gibbs phenomenon.
We know the terms in the
Fourier series, with a jump.
And if you computed--
Make it the periodic case,
if you've computed the
terms in the Fourier series
they would stay
near here and then
I'd see the famous
Gibbs stuff here.
So that-- You know,
it's quite pleasant
to see the printout of
the Gibbs phenomenon.
Not getting any
shorter, just moving
closer to the jump as you
increase the number of terms.
Yeah, it's quite interesting.
But couldn't do everything.
Yeah, ready for more.
Any questions?
Well, these are good.
Yes, thanks.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: With
cyclic convolutions.
OK, what could I do with
cyclic convolutions?
Let's see.
What should I do with
cyclic convolutions?
I better make a little space.
Let me make a little
space and think.
Anybody got a suggested problem
for a cyclic convolution?
I mean, one type of
problem would certainly
be if I gave you a
cyclic convolution
and asked for-- I mean, the
direct way would be to say OK,
what's the cyclic convolution
of (1, 4, 2) cyclically
with (2, 1, 3) or something.
But you could-- That's
just a calculation,
so you would get that.
I won't discuss that further.
Now suppose I ask it with
the unknown, the thing
that I don't know here?
So let me do that.
Shall I say three,
yeah. (3, 1, 1).
Cyclically convolved with
some unknown (x_0, x_1, x_2)
equals some
right-hand side, what
should we take for the
right-hand side? (1, 1, 1),
for example?
OK, I'll erase the top one.
OK, how would you go with that?
So that's three by
three, three unknowns.
It's linear, so somehow
I could write that
as three equations
in three unknowns.
The question is how do I
get some insight into this.
And when I'm seeing
a convolution, what's
my immediate thought?
Transform.
That's what this
month is all about.
November.
So I'll take the
DFT of everything.
So what's the discrete Fourier
transform of (1, 1, 1)?
Up there is going
to be the transform.
So let me call it x_0
hat, x_1 hat, x_2 hat.
Just to emphasize.
So N is three here,
in this problem.
Or maybe c_0, c_1,
c_2 you might prefer.
Whatever.
And now this is going
to be a multiplication,
so in MATLAB notation
will be a dot star, right?
And so now I have to--
These are the known ones,
so what's the discrete Fourier
transform of (1, 1, 1),
the cyclic convolution of that?
It's (1, 0, 0) is it?
Or it's (3, 0, 0)?
Is it three-- I guess when
I asked that question,
you're open to two answers.
You could either be going from
x space to frequency space
or frequency to the other.
Because I haven't told
you what space we're in.
OK, let's go with that one.
How did you get to there?
You multiplied by the three
by three Fourier matrix,
is that what you did?
Alright, so now can
you do that here?
So separately I have to
do a little multiplication
of the three by
three Fourier matrix.
One, one-- Sorry,
let me get it right.
So I'm going to transform this.
Make a little space here.
Transform that.
So it's 1, 1, 1,
1, 1 and this is
w, w squared, w squared
and w to the fourth,
which is the same as w.
OK, and now I want to
multiply that by (3, 1, 1).
And get the answer there.
OK, so what do I have?
Five.
And what is that other one?
Oh, boy.
What is three plus
w plus w squared?
Anybody know that one?
Well, I do know what one
plus w plus w squared is.
It is zero.
Why is one plus w
plus w squared zero?
So I claim that if I have
three plus-- I think the answer
there is two.
And here I think I've also
got three, w, w squared,
I think if it was a one
the answer would be a zero.
But it's a three, so I
still have two there.
I think that's probably right.
Can I just remind you why?
There's one, there's w,
and there's w squared
and they add to zero.
Yeah, yeah.
For many reasons.
That's a very, very,
handy property.
That the sum of the
nth roots of one
add to zero, OK, so
now where I am I?
So I got (5, 2, 2).
So I've transformed.
Now what do I do next?
I divide.
So this is telling me that this
is three separate equations.
There's three, 2x_1 hat is zero.
Right?
No, x_2 hat.
And 2x_2 hat.
Sorry, one was right.
And 2x_2 hat is zero.
I'm just doing
the multiplication
as I'm supposed to.
In the other space it's at each,
for each component separately.
So now I know x_0 hat is
3/5, and the others are zero.
So now I know what
these numbers are.
Oh, yeah. (3/5, 0, 0).
And now what?
I mean, that statement's
clearly true, right?
Point star means five
times this gives me three.
Two times zero gives me zero,
two times zero gives zero.
So I'm golden, but
I'm not finished.
So that's not x,
that's its transform.
So what do I have to do?
Go back.
OK, so now can you
tell me what this is?
Up to a factor of 1/N,
or N, which we may
have to figure out separately.
So apart from this possibly
appearing, and probably
appearing, give me
an idea of what's
the inverse transform of
that? (3/5, 3/5, 3/5), good.
3/5, all three times.
OK, and now I can check
to see if it's right.
And again, I have not attempted
to get the 1/N's right,
I've just waited to the end.
So now I'll just
do this convolution
and see if I really
do get (1, 1, 1).
So can we do that convolution?
What's the typical,
say, this guy.
Where does that come
from in the convolution?
It comes from this, times what?
This.
That's the constant, right?
And that's the constant.
Contributes to the constant.
And what other products
contribute to the constant?
So we're really seeing--
Thanks you for this question.
So this one
multiplies which one?
The answer is, this one
multiplies this guy.
You may say don't worry me about
it because they're the same.
But it's nice to know.
So this one multiplies this one.
And this guy
multiplies this guy.
And we'll remember
in a minute why.
And then you add them up,
that's what convolution is.
So I'm getting 9/5+3/5+3/5
is 15/5, so that's three.
So what's your conclusion here?
I should divide by three, right?
So I should divide by three.
So that's easy to do.
Those will all be one.
Yeah, OK.
So that's the right
answer, right?
And then I check
that it's right.
So let me just close by
remembering why was it--
So I'm doing just a
forward convolution here.
Solving the equation
was a deconvolution,
figuring out that x.
But now that I've got it
and I'm just checking,
that's just do it
forward and see
if you got the right answer.
And so we're just
remembering what
it means to do a convolution.
So you remember the
point about convolutions.
That if I'm convolving (a,
b, c) cyclically with (d, e,
f), that's a constant term.
Just tell me again, now, what's
the constant terms in this?
It's ad plus b times what?
This is the first term
in the convolution.
You remember that, the day
we brought convolutions
into the course?
What does b multiply? f, why f.
Because b is the coefficient of
w, if I'm taking polynomials,
this is a plus bw
plus c w squared,
and this corresponds to d
plus ew plus f w squared.
And I'm looking
for the constant.
So I get an a times a
d gives me a constant.
bw times what? times
f w squared gives me
the w cubed, which is
the one, so that bf here
and then there's a ce.
Because c w squared
multiplying ew
gives me the w cubed,
the one which folds in.
Yeah, OK, so anyway.
That's a quick reminder
of cyclic convolutions.
That was a good
question to ask, yeah.
You know, I fully realize this,
especially this third topic,
lots of things like this.
Straightforward if
you have lots of time,
but we had to keep moving.
So remembering what
cyclic convolution was
is a good chance to do it.